[Music]
you all know now that I'm having a boy I
don't have to hide it anymore fast
forward to February and Sophia Grace is
officially a mom to a baby boy
over 10 years after her breakout moment
on The Ellen Degeneres Show the singer
revealed she and her boyfriend welcomed
their first child together on February
26th with this sweet black and white
photo of their newborn's hands I know
it's strange isn't it it's really weird
I mean like it must feel weird to walk
out we were so nervous
Ellen congratulated Sophia with a
reference to her time on her daytime
talk show writing welcome to the world
Nicki Minaj the third because we all
know
I'm a bad Sophia and her cousin
Rosie have come a long way since Ellen
featured them on the show in 2011. after
they went viral for their Nikki Super
Bass tribute
[Music]
it's been really fun because I when I
was younger I never thought like I would
be singing and stuff the answer there
were both different people but we're
obviously cousins and like I'm so proud
of her and she's so proud of me Sophia
eventually traded covers for a singing
career of her own
[Music]
and while she's kept up posting YouTube
videos the 19 year old surprise fans in
October when she revealed she was five
months pregnant I'm sure a lot of you
gonna be very shocked because it
probably was quite unexpected as you can
see there you can sort of see the arm
this is like the head this is the arm
and it's sucking his thumb there and
then that's the belly Sophia's baby
boy's name has yet to be revealed but
she did share what it won't be ahead of
giving birth Kobe Oakley Caden Johnny
congrats to Sophia and her little bundle
of joy
[Music]
laughs